hey how's it going my name is Pierre the
game is out the complete game is out
what the [ __ ] about that and pretty go
we can play story story mode babe Gila
Beast
zero gee I never try that let's try that
what the hell is this
the hell is going on do I have a jet
pack on my back okay I do have a jet
pack on my back okay
I was worried that there was not a jet
pack on my toes oh my god this is making
me motion sick what is that Poli there
is however one more level that we need
to conquer cuz I'm an MLG pro at this
game
alright where are we going but we
started with that where the [ __ ] am I
that's the real question
there we go nailed it alright this is
too easy for me let's spice it up a bit
dammit stop go on suck it up suck it up
man there thank you
this bread has a [ __ ] D by issue stop
walking backwards you're walking
backwards alright here we come
oh so something fake Donny love that
don't make me spank you ah I can't hold
on biz
you're a bread oh you're a proud race
but goddamn do you suck
Jesus Jam it's Jesus Jam oh sweet
euphoric butter mixed with heroin he
gives me strength to do this pretty good
there it is we did it we did it now I
don't know where to go after this so
it's quite quite a problem it is it is
yeah [ __ ] you [ __ ] up ah I first get
there it is everyone knows wind chills
are [ __ ] clean am i right
why is the interior of this car vacant
doc doc hey pants
hi dear me no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no I said no
what are you doing magazine magazine mag
magazine use a [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay we need to hit that switch somehow
got it no problem I played this game
before I was born in my mom's uterus I
programmed this game and I installed a
tiny little computer so I could prepare
for this moment breasts no problem
I wasn't ready I was literally born
ready
there it is we're inside I repeat we're
inside I think wait the switch oh god
what am I going what is going what is
happening with my left what did I do
alright so got electricity going where
there maybe I just need to go underneath
it no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no nope nope if you
betray me again the magazine I swear now
we will go on that thing push the
explosive thing and with Sim salabim
we will win I can feel it in my fingers
I feel it in my toes
oh god okay I didn't ask for this when I
signed up in grade school what do we do
now what do we do now no iris you're
squishing me kiss flashback it was at
this point that the patient started
exhibiting signs of insanity Brad
right right okay oh god no oh my god
oh my god I did not [ __ ] a bridge my
entire [ __ ]
I think we need to start the blue thing
this is [ __ ] ridiculous okay this is
pretty awesome I think this is our only
[ __ ] chance to do this huh grab it
grab it you [ __ ] grab it you yes
balance strength fatality I don't I
don't [ __ ] get we're done we did so
much what else what else do you want
from me
all right we're gonna roll over here and
touch there oh I can't touch there come
on come on Oh what percent Oh No Oh
never let go never give up ah you're let
go you [ __ ]
hey no fair
it ain't over I'll never die
we go I can't believe we're uh huh why
why do you do that why do you do this
stop